[Musique]
la grande java c'est le premier film de
charlot oui c'est le premier film
commence à se décider
c'était une vieille ambition déjà autres
car un film et ça s'est décidé il ya non
pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut parler d'ores
et déjà messieurs des marx brothers
français c'était un peu trop tôt
non c'est faux c'est ton est fantastique
c'est pour ça qu'on en parle parce qu'
on essaie vraiment de lyon oullins
talent extraordinaire chez lui les
critiques et d'après les critiques qui
paraît qu'on est très bon alors je mets
le croire je crois tout ce qu'on te dit
autoriser qu'il n' y ait six vous qui
avez trouvé les gags du pin un petit peu
les chalon beaucoup moi et le reste dans
le mouvement
c'est toi et lui d'ailleurs ce monsieur
qui revient du rallye monte-carlo coincé
entre deux fils n'a pas duré bien
longtemps loin du temps mais ça n'a pas
duré bien longtemps parce que oui c'est
vrai c'est vrai oui c'est vrai
d'ailleurs mais je vais y retourner
je vais retourner dans un virage sous à
l'intention de faire d'autres d'autres
films oui oui oui oui alors appel au
producteur
après le polisseur écoulée nous regarder
nous l'arrêt noah producteurs nous vous
ai rien monsieur le producteur de vous
exercez vous voulez et charlot ont
vaguement l'intention de faire un
western no comment on voyait un western
manière charlot
[Musique]
avec des révolvers d'années de jouer
tsonga s'arrête et moi j'ai déjà j'ai
déjà noter les dates de toute façon je
crois qu'on est libre d'en voir à partir
du là s'est passé cela n'en fait sage
quidam des rendez vous mais les centres
intéressants
ces divers rendez vous avec six plaqués
au milieu de votre agenda vous avez
sorti un disque aussi là c'est une
oeuvre impérissable quel est le thème de
merci patron le thème c'est les
remerciements
vous êtes pencher un peu sur la
condition ouvrière tout ne cessa
exactement on a jugé que les ouvriers
étaient contents et qu'il fallait qu'il
le dise
quand on arrive à l'usiné la gaieté nous
illumine l'idée de faire nos buteurs
nous remplit toutes bonnes aaa d'humeur
égale et joyeuse de nous courons vers la
pointeuse
le temps d'enfiler nos bleus et nous
voilà tout heureux
là
merci patron
quel plaisir de travailler pour nous on
est heureux pour merci patron merci
patron
ce qu'un beau paix d'ici bas
un jour
dieu vous le rendra quand on pense à
tout l'argent qu'aux fins de mois on
vous prend nous avons tous un peu honte
d'être aussi près de notre tout le monde
à la maison où ça dort avec passion bush
d'être notre bonheur et nous chantons
rôle aux anges
leïla leïla
merci patron de travailler pour être
heureux rendez vous
merci patron
patron que vous faites ici bas
un jour dieu le voudra
il arrive là
il est plus petit que le jardin
quant à
est encore en cours
[Musique]